all i've seen in my twitter feed this
past week is people arguing about
valorent callouts so i've decided that
today i'm going to test liz on her map
knowledge i'll show her random spots on
various maps and she has to tell me what
the callout is all right let's do it
wine okay yeah that one might have been
a bit too easy to start with mail
okay
maybe this isn't too easy drop okay all
right 100 so far 350.
shout out to that one person in the
comment section and said i don't think
she plays valor and drop but i've also
heard it called shoot i'll give you a
half point for that one it is actually
called mid shoot i call this one among
us to be honest mcdonald's donald's hell
yeah mcdonald's is the best call out
there do people call it anything else
i've heard people say arches too that's
boring
snowman
of course i love the woolstone man
confession when you're attacking a i
always call that one i'm gonna have to
find some more obscure spots you think
you can defeat me
i'm so smart big brain five head